this is a production of cornell
university
okay so we're set up here to measure
another important physical property of
soil
and we're going to look at the
infiltration rate so we have
our bucket of water some measuring
devices
our rulers and a shovel we're going to
make a hole
so we're going to make a hole we're
going to wet the inside of the hole
and then we're going to after the soil
on the edges has become saturated we're
going to fill the hole
and use the the measuring sticks
in order to take the rate of drain down
and therefore measure the infiltration
rate of the soil and we're going to
convert that into inches per hour
so it starts with the hole i'm gonna
remove the organic material from above
i just have a little bit of turf
okay that's out of the way i'm gonna
cut down
we're gonna go about nine to twelve
inches wide and nine to twelve inches
deep here
okay that's all cleaned up so now we
have our open test pit now you can
imagine that this soil actually is very
very dry
and if we don't actually wet it so that
we overwhelm the forces of adhesion
we'll actually get lateral movement in
the water what we want is water
uh moving by gravity so we'll first wet
the hole
and so we'll actually reduce the amount
of lateral flow of water
by adhesion we might actually fill it up
fully and let it drain and then do the
test the second time
[Music]
but for this purpose we're going to fill
it up
and then do a measurement
measure our starting point where the
water is and then we'll wait
typically 10 or 15 minutes to see how
much the water
percolates downward and we multiply by
either
uh six or four to come up to inches per
hour
okay we're at seven and a half inches
at 902 okay well we've hit our 10-minute
mark
just past and we'll take our second
reading now
okay well we've only drained down a
quarter inch
so we want to convert that into inches
per hour to standardize
the value so let's see here a quarter
inch and
10 minutes times six is six quarters
or an inch and a half per hour
which is very poorly drained we usually
consider
four inches per hour or less somewhat
limiting
and we call that poorly drained in our
field test
likely what we're seeing here are some
of the
impacts from the foot traffic in this
pathway in the garden
creating a compacted soils where soil
infiltration has been limited
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu